I I would love to have just the ladies
on the panel go around and just give you
could choose your younger self or you
can kind of choose just the younger
generation and just say you know what is
your advice for ladies today uh you know
and if you could kind of sum up your
best advice you would give you know a
young woman that's trying to figure out
what she wants out of life and dating
and happiness what would be kind of that
advice
be for me it's a pretty General one oh
sorry please go on S sorry um it's a
pretty General one but it really is so
incredibly true and it's who you
surround yourself with is who you sort
of become so I think the cliche is like
The Five People You surround yourself
with is is the is what you do end up
becoming so basically don't surround
yourself with people that are lazy that
um are just bad people or don't don't
share your beliefs I think in my 20s
especially I probably surrounded myself
with people not like bad people just
unmotivated uninteresting uninspired
people and I feel like I'm changing that
more in my 30s now but I think you have
to be you have to be so so so careful
who you spend the most time with who you
spend the most time talking to are these
people going to inspire you are they
going to teach you things are they going
to encourage you are they going to do
all those sorts of things that it's I
think it's something that maybe looked
but that would be that would be probably
the one thing I would say just be care
be very careful who you surround
yourself with day to
day
um I would say three things number one
stay off harmonal birth control number
two take care of your body and number
three like we all want to be with a good
man with a high value man don't waste
your young years squandering is not even
a word squandering don't waste your
years young
years because and don't be don't go
after like the the successful man it's I
think it's better I think girls need to
exercise discernment and find a man who
you know he can be young but he has
potential if he's ambitious and he has
his right has the right values like what
my mom always said to me she's like if
you want to marry a general you need to
date him as a
soldier so don't be don't be too picky
but keep your standards high as a women
we need to keep our standards High
because men will rise to the standards
that we set them if your standards are
low men will have no incentive to get
out of their mom's basement and wash
their Cheeto State fingers and get off
the PlayStation they will just be happy
with and that's bad for men as well
because we want men to be good we want
men to be to grow because we need strong
men so we need to incentivize we need to
inspire men and the way we can Inspire
them is to be kind virtuous learn skills
that is going to make you a desirable
candidate as um as a future partner
honestly like it's it's not too
difficult but we that's what I want to
do is educate young ladies and
that's what I write about on my Twitter
I talk about all of this um for men for
women because I think it starts with
education what rich said lobing the
government I don't think that's going to
work because they're they're too
powerful they're not going to
listen um but it's a nice thought but I
think it's people can do things on an
individual level so I think it starts
with education and Rich your doing it
Chris you're doing it I'm doing a little
bit of it but I'm super passionate about
it so maybe that will grow in the future
yeah I just want to want to touch on
something before the other two girls um
you have the final worlds she said
something interesting there right she
said you know if you want to be with the
general you have to date the soldier
right and it's like for the most part I
think women in the west aren't generally
King makers they want to be with a king
but they're not King makers now your
background's Eastern Eastern European
was
it I'm from the Caucasus area so it's um
yeah Eastern Eastern European but there
a lot of generals where you grow up or
is it mostly
soldiers it's mostly soldiers so I mean
you're for General then I'm sorry so
then you're forced to make a general if
you want to be with the general so you
have to be yes yes yes yes no it's just
a cultural thing that I noticed because
I like you know with the West like most
western women are like figure it up
buddy like you know why you wasting my
time right King anyway um Desiree go
ahead final words you're talking to your
20-year- old self what advice would you
give just
to focus on
staying pure
sweet and not not so defensive just
agreeable and
but that's not going to a young 20y old
self that's going to be hard
to you probably wouldn't listen right
yeah it's not too hard actually if
anything it's life is on easy mode I
asked my boyfriend I was like what would
what can I do to be a better girlfriend
what do what do you require of me and he
just said just be
fit uh be loyal to me and just work on
yourself just be Happ happy I like you
when you're happy and I'm like life is
easy for
me I think you reminded me Elena of your
point where a lot of women will have a
laundry list of things they want from a
man but they won't consider what they
actually are giving back in return like
what if you have this long laundry list
what exactly are you bringing to the
table it's something I think a lot of
women women don't consider and I try to
I try to consider that Within Myself or
what am I bringing to the table as well
and I think that's something other women
need to think about before they want a
six5 six figure earning the six Sixers I
think you mentioned in a video Rich uh I
can't remember all of them it's like six
we require that as women and I think I
think it's good that we keep our
standards high like I said because you
know hypergamy is real we need to have
to choose the best fathers for our kids
you know Superior genetics
resources but they don't require too
much from us loyalty yeah I was gonna
say
like easy if the ladies on the panel and
any gals watching this right now could
take anything you know from what she
just said
it's when he's dealing with something
difficult even if he's just changing a
tire on a a cart like make him a
sandwich don't even ask him if he wants
a sandwich just make them a sandwich
right and if there's something difficult
in his life going on hey what can I do
to be useful here right like I see you
struggling with this right um Melanie
final words you're talking your
20-year-old self what advice you give
really quick before I say that on just
what you said Rich about the sandwich uh
my son I think he was in third grade
gave me a note for Mother's Day and it
said Mom thank you for always putting
grapes in my lunch giving me good food
making my bed cozy that's all a boy
needs it was so profound I was like it's
true they're just simple feed me food
make my bed cozy I'm good uh to my
20-year-old
self to look back I didn't have this
understanding but the way you've talked
about holding frame and what that means
for a woman is so incredible and so
beautiful and I wish I would have
understood more about
that because that's going to benefit
supporting the man and you get to be
more of a woman when when you're in that
frame and a man that's doing the work
and creating a frame like
that is benefiting women so that's why
if women if come and say oh you know
rich is a misogynist moth this that the
fact you have done the work and create
frame you're bettering the lives for
women in general so the frame is such a
important cool thing and it's it covers
so many different things within a
relationship but that's been a big
takeaway for me I wish I'd understood
that more awesome I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out